hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over another video from Bobby
Fischer for the upcoming graphic novel
Bobby Fischer the knight who killed the
Kings do you guys have any questions
I've been playing some clips before the
videos it's kind of give you a teaser
but if you have any questions about the
graphic novel it's going to be pretty
awesome I'll be answering a lot of
questions you guys have about the
graphic novel in the next video so
definitely feel free to add a comment or
you can always email me and I will
answer your questions in there as well
today's video is going to be from the
first ever u.s. championship that Bobby
Fischer played in championship was 1957
1958 now Bobby Fischer played in eight
different US Championships and he
actually won all eight of them so he's
eight Freight that's not a bad a
statistic if you're looking for a
winning streak there so this was the
first championship they Bobby Fischer
ever won so 57 58 and he was 14 years of
age now when he won Bobby Fischer became
the youngest US Champion ever so I don't
know if you are 14 or older
but if you can just imagine being 14 and
being the best chess player in the
United States that is a huge deal and
Bobby Fischer at the time was probably
rated about 2,400 to about 2,500 after
the tournament he became an
international master so kind of give you
an idea of you know where he was as far
as his you know chess career as far as
his chest knowledge his opponent in the
game today just to kind of give you a
you know brief background his opponent
was ed Mar - now at this time ed Mar was
about 20 years old when they played in
the eight years that Bobby Fischer
played in the US Championships there
were only three people that beat him
which is pretty amazing that for eight
years that he played only three people
actually beat him in a game now Bobby
Fischer would win the entire tournament
but ed Marr Minnis although he did not
beat Bobby Fischer in this particular
tournament was one of those three
individuals so a very very strong us
player and so this
is one of my favorite games from Bobby
Fischer's first-ever US championship now
in this game we do have Bobby Fischer
playing the white pieces and we have ed
Martinez playing the black pieces so as
Bobby Fischer normally did he started
out with pawn to e4 Bobby Fischer liked
to change things up but he did always
like to start with pawn to e4 in black
ed Martinez plays pawn to d6 now this is
the perk defense so kind of just some
background as far as what both sides are
going to be going after black pretty
much is conceding the center of the
board
White's going to be able to play pawn to
d4 which is exactly what Bobby Fischer
does and this perk defense is a hyper
modern offense meaning the black early
on is not going to push forward very
hard with his pawns instead he's going
to try to from the outside try to
control the center of the board with his
minor pieces so feeing carrying his
Bishop to g7 he could always feel kid it
was Bishop to b7 really try to get his
Knights involved into the game try to
control the center of the board and only
once he has an attack that he thinks he
can undermine White's position in the
center then and only then will he try to
counter-attack and then take over the
center of the board obviously the
similar board is very very important in
chess so at some time black definitely
wants to have Center control of the
board so early on Bobby Fischer does
have the advantage with pawn to d4 and
blacks going to continue with the
mainline men displays Knight to f6 again
hyper-modern defense trying to control
the center and attack with his minor
pieces Bobby Fischer white continues
with Knight to c3 and men this black
pieces plays pawn to g6 now what I
really enjoy about studying games that
Bobby Fischer played especially early on
you know this he's only 14 is he really
starts to innovate a lot of the openings
that we see today that you know for us
if we study it's book lines and even
computer incidence if you look at them
they're book lines but when Bobby
Fischer played him a lot of time he was
theorizing what they should play you
know how they should play some of the
best moves in the
variations his next move Bishop to g5 it
definitely gets out his dark square
Bishop which a lot of times is more
difficult for white to get involved into
the game but this move really didn't
become popular until the 60s Robert
Byrne actually introduced this a lot
into the game as far as theory behind it
but Bobby Fischer in his first ever u.s.
championship plays you know a new move
which I'm sure he had studied very very
often probably had a lot of theory
behind it himself
it just wasn't widespread so very
interesting that even early on in his
career at the age of 14 he was already
thinking about new ways of playing chess
that other people really hadn't come to
yet so from here blacks going to come to
Bishop to g7 and White's going to play
Queen to d2 again supporting this Bishop
here on g5 also getting ready to castle
on the Queen set typically any time you
start to develop one of your minor
pieces or your major pieces to one side
that's typically where you're going to
Castle so if Bobby Fischer instead
decides to start out with his Knight to
f3 and then get his LightSquared Bishop
involvement to the game you would
typically see White Castle on the Kings
side but in this case since Bobby
Fischer decided to get his knighted ball
to c3 and then his dark square Bishop
and his Minor
excuse me his major piece here to d2
more than likely
Bobby Fischer in this case why it's
going to be castling on the Queen side
now from here men this does have a few
options he could always try to bring his
knight to c6 simple development move
again hyper-modern trying to control the
center of the board with his minor
pieces he could even bring his Knight to
d7 as far as opening book theory this is
this is okay nowadays that a lot of
people have gone over this Knight to d7
does play fairly well black could also
castle on the Kings side again after he
Fein kiddoes his Bishop to g7 this is a
very safe defense for black and he does
also have the option of kicking this
bishop with pawn to h6 now this does
come with a a tidbit of information
anytime
you start to push up pawns once you fee
and keto to your Bishop your your King
side does become a lot weaker so in this
case the King side from black is much
weaker so he's going to look to castle
on the Queen side if he does have that
option and he really wants to keep the
Queen side much safer now since the King
side you know it's kind of pushing
forward this is not bad by any means but
it does weaken the King set so something
to keep along we're going to kind of be
going over the strengths and weaknesses
of both the king side in the Queen side
but this is what men this plays he plays
pawn to h6 and it kicks back the bishop
here to f4 Bobby Fischer again bringing
his Bishop back to f4 so we can put a
lot of pressure on the center of the
board still really trying to control the
turn of the board but obviously he does
need to retreat his Bishop back now
blacks going to play pawn to c6 again
from here black does need to be careful
now pawn to c6 does give him some
options you know later on he can bring
his Knight to d7 he does open up the
window for his Queen to come to a5 if he
wants to make it he's still looking to
castle on the Queen side
he's also blocking this b5 square very
important square if white ever wanted to
develop his minor pieces his Bishop
let's say to b5 get that involved into
the game it is also you know defending
the knight coming here to b5 it's
definitely you know blocking this square
here on b5 now Bobby Fischer castles on
the Queen side is we had talked about
before anytime you start to develop you
do want to get your King to safety as
soon as possible and black from here
Menace plays Queen to a5 I'm starting to
attack on the Queen side again any time
your opponent kind of shows their hand
to you and tells you what side they're
going to have their King on the rest of
the game in some way you want to start
to attack that one way or another it
could be early on into the game or you
could build a tack later on into the
game from here Bobby Fischer is going to
play King to be one in you'll see this a
lot obviously Bobby Fischer does have
the night here on c3
defending this pawn on a1 but you never
want to have your minor pieces tied down
to a particular pawn
our particular square your minor pieces
really need to be controlling the center
the board but later on you actually want
them to be attacking and have your major
pieces actually supporting those as well
so you really don't want to have this
night tied down to this pawn on a two so
the King just is going to come over to
be one and protect this pawn here on a
two now from here blacks going to play
pawn to g5 and I really like this
because you know black does have the
opportunity to castle on the Queen side
later on and he's really starting to
make a push on on the King side here
there's not really a lot of options for
the dark square bishop here for white so
really putting a lot of pressure on
white here to do something productive
now Bobby Fischer decides to retreat his
Bishop back to g3
and from here Menace plays Knight to h5
looking to exchange off his knight for
this dark square bishop here on g3
there's not really a lot of squares the
Bobby Fischer can now move his Bishop so
typically you you will see a trade-off
here for the night and the dark square
Bishop most times at high level play
early on into the games is you can open
up the board very easily a lot more
easily than you can close the game
Bishop's tend to fare better a lot of
people like a bishop pair especially
when they can open it up so anytime a
lot of it if a you know high-level chess
player can trade off one of their nights
for a bishop you typically will see that
early on so if you're kind of curious
why this Knights coming to h5 on the rim
you know typically a knight on the rim
is dim but in this particular case he's
just going you know to trade off the
night here on g3 white plays Bishop to
c4 you know a lot of players get bogged
down they say you know what I'm going to
lose this Bishop here on g3 I'm going to
trade it off you know what's really the
best way to recapture and Bobby Fischer
just he realized he's going to have to
trade that off so he instead really
starts to focus on what his you know
attacks going to be and really start to
develop his pieces one of the big things
you always want to do in chess game is
you want to develop your minor pieces
and you want to develop them towards the
center of the
word this see Foursquare is very
important square it's attacking the f7
square from black which is a huge
weakness early on to the game it's the
only square from black that's only
defended by the King so no or the other
none of the other pieces can defend the
pawn early on into the game so huge
weakness for black early on this f7
Square and that's exactly where Bobby
Fischer places his Bishop here on c4
attacking this pawn here on f7 now from
here black plays an interesting move
that actually don't agree with and he
plays pawn to b5 now the problem that I
have with this is and I'll kind of go
over some different variations right
here's the King side from black is
already weak and that's okay if the
Queen side is strong and you can
actually make a very strong push from
the Kings side the problem right here is
Bobby Fischer has a very very strong
defense on the Queen side for his King
and so if you look at black where is his
King really going to go the Kings side
is the king side is weak and now he's
kind of opened up his Queen side here
you know I think it would have been a
much better play if instead of bringing
his you know pawn down to b5 if he tried
something you know Knight to d7 looking
to get that involved into the middle of
the board you know if he wanted to later
on he could play pawn to e5 really start
to push forward again trying to counter
play in the center of the board try to
take back the center of the board a very
nice square from black right here on d7
but instead you know he kind of over
extends he plays pawn to b5 you know
seems logical trying to you know kick
off this Bishop here on before but
really does overextend himself now Bobby
Fischer actually has two options here if
you study any amount of Bobby Fischer's
play he is he's so prone to just bring
his Bishop back to b3 still lying down
on this f7 square you know trying to eye
down on this long diagonal Bobby Fischer
actually made a mistake here though he
did have the opportunity to actually
just capture here on B
five now as you can see the Queen
there's a discovered attack on the Queen
here on a5 so the Queen can't come and
capture on b5 obviously you know white
would recapture with his Bishop and he
can also not take with his pawn here on
b5 because again his queen is hanging
here on a5 now if he does capture if he
decides to capture right here and you
say you know okay well you know men this
could have now just taken the the night
here on b5 this would actually be
incorrect play as well because Bobby
Fischer could have now brought his
Bishop to d5 he would have taken this
rook here on a8 there's no way to
prevent this and white would be up a lot
of material in this situation so you
know Bobby Fischer dead he kind of let
one go by here he definitely could have
gone up in material but you know he kind
of played it safer route he decided you
know I'm gonna bring my bishop back to
b3 I have a much better foundation as
far as you know protection for my king
you know he's probably played this
situation many many times before and if
he kind of looks at it he really doesn't
have to be you know too aggressive black
really is kind of divvying his own grave
in the situation it's kind of
overextending all his pawns without
really doing too much damage to Bobby
Fischer's entire structure so you know
it shows us safe route and just played
Bishop to b3 now after the bishop comes
back to b3 med this now brings his
Knight to d7 definitely good square he
needs to get his knight involved into
the action Bobby Fischer's almost
complete as far as his development he
does need to get this knight involved
into the game and then he will correct
connect his rooks a lot of time you as
far as you know completing development
you'll hear that you'll get all your
minor pieces involved into the game
get out your queen castle on one side
and then connect your rooks you
definitely want your Rex rooks connect
into the game they have a lot more
mobility and they definitely work well
together so you know Knight to d7 blacks
really looking to castle on the Queen
side here again his King side is getting
you know very very extended but you know
again his queen side is as well
bobby fisher' now plays pawn to f4 he
starts to attack on the Kings side just
to make sure trying to figure out
exactly where memnos is going to castle
he does still have the option to castle
on the Kings side if he wants to but
this f4 is a very aggressive move trying
to push forward controlling the soon the
board and really making sure that black
kind of shows his hand as far as what
he's going to do because if he gets rid
of this pawn here on g5 it's going to be
very difficult to castle on the Kings
side because there's going to be a
semi-open file on the G file from here
black plays Knight takes on g3 I think
it might have been a little better move
to actually play pawn to b4 again if
you're going to push on the Queen side
you can't do it half-hearted
you know pushing pawn to b4 making this
Knight go somewhere obviously it can't
come here to defy it would lose material
you know would have to have a passive
move like you know Knight to e2 so
definitely putting a lot of pressure on
white but instead you know he does the
exchange that Bobby Fischer has kind of
been waiting for for a few moves and he
takes thereon g3 and white recaptures
with his pawn on g3 opening up this semi
open file for the rook here on h1 now
black pushes forward with his pawn to g4
interesting move really trying to
solidify these double pawns here on g4
and g3 again I think instead of you know
pushing forward to g4 I think it
probably would have been a good move for
black to continue the pressure to play
pawn to b4 he kind of has this you know
possibility to play for a long time and
he just really never takes advantage of
it but instead he does play pawn to g4
and then Bobby Fischer pushes forward
with pawn to e5 if you kind of look at
the board Bobby Fischer really has both
sides are equal in material but Bobby
Fischer has a very very strong defense
in front of his King and he can really
start to attack the center of the board
both the Queen side in the king side
black are kind of weak so if you kind of
have weaknesses on both side Bobby
Fischer just decides that he's going to
attack the middle and one of the sides
is going to crumble one of the sides is
going to have to kind of you know
counter-attack with all their minor
pieces and pawns and so he's going to be
able to either attack on the Queen side
or the King side so from here black
decided to play pawn to d5 now I do
think he did have some other options
here instead of you know d6 again as we
talked about he does have this pawn to
b4 move if he wants to but instead you
know he plays pawn to d5 Bobby Fischer
plays pawn to f5 again really putting
pressure on the center of the board and
just pushing up his pawns his pawns are
being supported you know by each other
if he wants to he can always bring his
rooks involved into the game to kind of
support from the back so he's just kind
of pushing forward putting a lot of
pressure on black black starting to
really lose a lot of space here there's
not a lot of great squares for him to go
his Queen over here on a five is kind of
hanging out on its own
it's really hard for black right now to
strategize where he's going to go next
menace in this situation decides to
bring his knight to b6 really eyeing
down on outpost on c4 if he wants to
anytime there's an exchange here he can
open up this B file really opening up a
strong attack on the on the Queen side
so that's kind of what Menace is looking
for in this situation but instead you
know white looks at this and sees kind
of a lot of the material from black is
shifted towards the Queen side Fischer
feels pretty confident that his King is
safe so he plays Queen to f4 really
eyeing down on this pawn to g4 and Bobby
Fischer you know really is just looking
for pawn to come to h5 that's really all
he wants
right now the bishop here on g7 is
defending this pawn on h6 so really
Bobby Fischer's just bringing his Queen
to f4 to kind of draw this pawn out kind
of overextend it even more so that he
can put a lot of
Sharan it later on into the game but
instead men displays an interesting move
which which I'm going to consider a
blunder you know the computer actually
considers it a blunder as well simply
because he just gives up material and he
plays pawn to e6 definitely one of the
significant pitfalls into the game
because he's just giving up this pawn on
g4 really not what you want to do
against Bobby Fischer just give up
material for absolutely no reason you
know again he could have always pushed
forward with before we've talked about
this before but instead he plays d6
and Bobby Fischer is going to take this
material right here you have to do keep
in mind that Bobby Fischer is now
attacking menaces Bishop here on g7 so
the bishop will have to move and the
bishops going to come back to f8 and
then Bobby Fischer is going to take with
his pawn on e6 and then black has to
recapture with his Bishop now if you
look at and you say you know why doesn't
he capture with his pawn well if he does
capture with his pawn then white can
just bring his queen to g6 and then
blacks in a whole lot of trouble black
can no longer castle because he's going
to have to move his King Black is down
the material and you know Bobby Fischer
can always bring his knight excuse me
his rook over to the F file and just
start to put a lot of pressure on the
black King this rook here on a 8 would
never get involved into the action so
it'd definitely be really really hard
for black 2 to finish so he does make
the correct choice and he recaptures
with his bishop here on e6 but as you
can kind of tell this bishop is kind of
tied down to this pawn here on f7 and
also supporting this pawn here on d5 but
he does capture with tempo the white
queen from Bobby Fischer is gonna have
to move back and he moves back to Queen
to f3 now Mendes decides it's now time
to castle so he castles on the Queen
side you know again if you kind of look
at it although he castled on the Queen
side the Queen side is still very very
vulnerable his all of his pawns are kind
of extended very quickly so Bobby
Fischer if you kind of look at kind
what's I what both sides need to do in
the situation now it's always good
anytime you approach a chess situation
is kind of look what's what material
both sides kind of who's winning in
material but also who's winning as far
as development who's king is safe who's
King isn't safe
whose pieces are actually doing
something whose are kind of tied back
it's not always about you know how many
people you have in the army it's about
how many people in the army are actually
fighting so if all your pieces are tied
up that's not as important if you have
you know four or five pieces actually
fighting in the battle so if we can look
at this Bobby Fischer has a good thing
going form although his LightSquared
Bishop here isn't doing too much his
King is very very protected and as you
can see you know black is his King side
is not protected it's kind of
discombobulated right now it's going to
be very very easy for him to just you
know protect his King on the Queen side
and kind of make room and attack on the
King side and eventually make his way
over and attack the King here on c8 so
from here white plays Knight to h3 again
he does need to get his minor pieces
involvement of the game he is yet to
move his Knight to h3 and one thing the
Bobby Fischer does better than anyone
I've ever seen play chess is he really
uses all this pieces together very very
well anytime you know a lot of times
people will play a piece or they'll move
one of their minor pieces I mean it's
what for one particular goal but Bobby
Fischer typically is moving his pieces
for multiple roles and goals typically
he wants all of his pieces to be
cohesive and work together so first
thing he needs to do is get his knight
involved into the game to h3
blacks going to now bring his rook to g8
anytime there is a semi-open file which
this g file is you definitely want your
rook on that file so definitely putting
a lot of pressure on this file right
here Bobby Fischer's always going to
have to be looking at that with his
queen or another one of his minor or
major pieces or else he will be giving
back that pawn that he got early on into
the game so from here Bobby Fischer just
brings his white queen back to f2 and
menís decides to go
and bring his Knight to c4 again as we
talked about looking to exchange and
then open up this B file for one of his
rooks or some of his other pieces right
now
now Bobby Fischer we look at this white
bishop right here on b3 is not doing
anything and it's probably not going to
be doing anything for a while so white
in this situation decides to go ahead
and trade off and black recaptures
recapturing towards the center typically
a good thing in chess getting ready to
eye down on this B file right now the
next room moves from white actually take
the advantage that he does have and kind
of brings it back to equality as far as
both sides you know if we kind of look
at it Bobby Fischer could easily play
Knight to f4 start to really put a lot
of pressure on black really start to
push up on the King side for right now
his King SOT
excuse me his Queen side is safe
defending the King here but again you
know Bobby Fischer being 14 this is his
first u.s. championship you know my
guess is nerves probably kind of got to
him he starts to play a little bit
passive what black actually started to
you know have this big attack start to
come up on the Queen side so next couple
moves Bobby Fischer starts to play a
little bit passive it doesn't actually
start to attack when he probably should
have so Bobby Fischer in this particular
place plays King to a 1 and black comes
to d7 getting ready to bring his rook
over to the b7 square and then really
start to attack on the Queen side of
white here Bobby Fischer now plays
Knight to be one again a very very
passive movie still could have brought
his knight over to f4 if you wanted to
pin start to put a lot of pressure on
black here definitely a passive move and
this kind of brought it back near
equality white still has a a small
advantage but black definitely has a
strong attack coming up from here black
decided to bring is rook over to b7 as
we talked about any time there's a semi
open file as this B file is you
definitely want to attack that and you
want to have your rook there
especially with the opponent's queen on
the able excuse me the king on the a1
square definitely targeting all your
major and minor pieces on that it's
definitely going to be a good thing now
Bobby Fischer now plays pawn to c3
really allowing this Queen here on f2 to
defend the pawn here on b2 and also
defending this key square on b4 black
does have this dark square bishop that
can always come into the game if you
wanted to and really just defending a
lot of big dark squares this pawn from
c3 actually very very good move from
white now black does play an interesting
move right here I think it kind of
wastes some time he definitely does have
some different options but he plays rook
to b6 now the count look at this it
doesn't really improve his position you
know he was kind of attacking the same
thing he was still you know has his rook
on the semi-open b file really what he
should have done is he needs to protect
his king right now he needs to get his
King on a dark square it's going to be
very very hard to attack that dark
square if he does bring his King over to
let's say be eight at any given time if
white were to take this bishop off of
the e6 square then the Queen can always
come to let's say f5 or you know g4
later on and attack these light squares
but if he hasn't on b8 then his King is
pretty much safe he could always if he
wanted to bring it over to a8 it would
be extremely safe but as you can see
he's really starting a huge attack
against the Queen side of white why it's
kind of being passive right now kind of
allowing black to do all this but
instead he kind of wastes a move he
plays rook to b6 doesn't really improve
anything kind of the same situations we
talked about you know he really wasn't
thinking about his King at all any time
you have a position whether it's
yourself or it's the u.s. championship
always think about what your objective
is and what you need to do that and
don't waste moves this pawn excuse me
this rook from b7
to be six definitely could have been
doing a lot more efficient things which
with his moves now white plays rook to
d2 again putting a lot of defense on
this pawn to be two he probably doesn't
need all this defense but again Bobby
Fischer is still up in material so he's
probably just trying to hold on to that
trying to make sure that black doesn't
sneak in for any crazy attacks here now
black makes a huge blunder right here
instead of going away from any potential
attacks he actually brings his king
closer to any potential attacks with
King to d7 now he's probably thinking
that he wants to get his dark squared
bishop involved into the game and then
he wants to swing his rook over into the
action to the B file to support his
other rook well that's all you know good
it would have been much better if he
would have brought his you know king
over to b8 and then a eight it would
have been much much harder for white to
actually you know get over and attack
that King you never want to bring your
King into the middle of the game when
your opponent has all of his major
pieces and two of his minor pieces now
once you reach towards the end game
Queens are off the board you know
there's not all the minor pieces and
both the rooks on the board then you
actually want to bring your King into
the game he's actually a huge asset to
your attack bringing him into this in
the game but when your opponent has all
these attacking pieces the center of the
board is not where you want your King
you actually want him protected in a
corner somewhere just hiding out hoping
that your opponent does not attack you
now if there's one thing that Bobby
Fischer does well it's he smells
weakness and he attacks weakness so he
realizes that Black has made a blunder
here he's brought his King closer to the
action and so he's going to attack that
weakness so Bobby Fischer now plays
Knight to f4 this is kind of the attack
on the King side he's been waiting for
he now has you know a strong defense
with his King here on a1 he's kind of
tucked in this corner and he's now going
to start to attack
black decides to bring his Bishop to e7
if we kind of look at it with this
exchange here let's let's just move the
pawn here to a6 after the exchange here
you know the King could always come here
to e6 and kind of become more out in the
open but if the pawn takes here on e6
then the Queen can come up here to f7
check the king and then win this rook
here on g8 so definitely wants to make
sure that he can't just come up to f7
and check so one of the ways that he can
do this is to early on bring his Bishop
to e7 so that's exactly what he does
here and then Bobby Fischer takes this
pawn here on h6 so you know this Bishop
here on f8 was protecting this pawn here
on h6 but no longer so Bobby Fischer
comes in and takes this also has a
strong attack he now has another major
piece involved into the game and again
black has his King into the center of
the board now blacks going to play a
rook to f8 trying to control and protect
this pawn here on f7 and Bobby Fischer
is going to play Queen to f3 he really
wants to make sure that his queen is on
light squares anytime he's going to
exchange off let's say with this Bishop
here on e6 he definitely wants his Queen
on a light square so if he wants to he
can get involved into the action and
attack at any given time with his Queen
here on f2 it's kind of passive it's not
doing a whole lot it's going to take a
few moves for him to get involved into
the action so he plays Queen to f3 again
Bobby Fischer's Queen side is safe so
all he's doing is trying to meticulously
bring all this pieces together on the
Queen's excuse me on the Kings side and
mount an attack so from here black plays
rook to a6 you know trying to come up
with some attack on the Queen side
attacking the White Queen excuse me the
White King but all white has to do is
play pawn to a3 and this pretty much
just thwarts any attack that black has
he does have the pawn that's protecting
this he also has the night here
they can also defend the square on a
three Black is now going to bring his
rook over to b8 again trying to try to
find some way to attack but this rook
here on b8 s not doing a whole lot it is
attacking this pawn here on b2 but too
little to bobby fischer's now going to
take with his knight on e6 and after the
exchange the King can't come right now
to e6 because the rook there on h6 so
he's going to take with his pawn here
and then Bobby Fischer's actually going
to sacrifice his rook here on e6 this
Bobby Fischer does again any time he
smells blood or weakness he's going to
attack that so he's willing to give up
this rook here on e6 now just kind of go
over the variation you know like Kevin
why can't he just take that definitely
want to show you guys that if he does
take the rook here on e6 then Bobby
Fischer can just play white - you know
Queen the g4 here the only possible move
we can't come to d6 Midna scant come
back to these seven you can't come to f6
his only move is King to f7 Bobby
Fischer can now play pawn to e6 and now
mid this has two options he can bring
his King to e8 if he wants to or he can
also bring his King to f8 e eights
actually going to lose quicker so we'll
kind of go over that variation if mid
this plays King to e8 then after the
Queen to g8 the bishop has to defend and
then it's checkmate for Bobby Fischer
now if he does move mid this does play
King to f8 then all Bobby Fischer has to
come in and play Queen to g6 and there
is absolutely no stopping the Queen
coming to f7 for checkmate now you know
min this could have if you wanted to
kind of you know slow up the game you
could have come down and captured and
then after the capture recapture and
then he takes you could have even
brought his rook down to be one if you
wanted to
after all the captures
Dunnan kind of menaces given all the
opportunities to delay the game you know
it's still inevitable no one can stop
the Queen coming to f7 so it's kind of
curious you know Bobby Fischer's giving
up that rook why can't the King just
take that that is the exact reason so I
think in this particular case mid this
actually gets more flustered because he
makes an even worse move so in this
particular case black probably should
have tried to bring his queen involved
into the action you know maybe Queen to
d8 he needs to protect you know his
bishop there on e7 but he also needs to
have a defender he needs to realize that
his attack against the court against the
white king is not going anywhere there's
actually not enough pieces coordinated
correctly to do an attack so he needs to
come up with a better idea Queen to d8
is a better idea here but instead he
plays Bishop takes on a three and Bobby
Fischer recaptures with his knight again
there's no great move for Midna s-- to
play in this situation the king is now
going to capture with his king here on
e6 and that's pretty much good game from
here Bobby Fischer plays Queen to g4 the
kings can come back to e7 and Bobby
Fischer plays rook to f2 getting ready
to come involved into the game you know
again blacks just kind of wishing that
something could happen on the Queen side
but it doesn't so a few more moves comes
brings his rook over to e8
which really doesn't do anything
productive but it doesn't really matter
Bobby Fischer now white plays Queen to
g5 check the King goes back to d7 you
know continue with the moves right here
white plays f5 check King goes over to
b8 white plays d7 and black in this
situation actually resigned there's no
way to stop Bobby Fischer coming to b7
checkmate now you know Midna sif he
wanted to could have always delayed the
game it could have brought his Queen
involved into the game he could have if
he wanted to Eve
you know taking this night and then
taking it with his rookie if you wanted
to but you know in this situation he
decided to just go ahead and resign so a
very very exciting game from a 14 year
old kid his first ever u.s. championship
to come in place someone six years older
than him and to win his very first u.s.
championship very very exciting
hope you guys enjoyed this hope you
learned something as far as looking at
different positions and thinking about
what both sides can do different ideas
that they can do an attack defending
your own King and then focusing on other
sides of the board or weaknesses that
you see your opponent have so definitely
leave comments let me go let me know
what you guys think about it also if you
have any questions for the graphic novel
it's going to be coming out in the
future but it's going to be pretty
awesome again Bobby Fischer the knight
who killed the king so hopefully you
guys do it the video and I'll see y'all
in part 3